Alex visorec bonjour Julien
c'est plus une émission c'est un club
échangiste
à féminiser les insultes parce que
généralement le champ lexical des
insultes est plutôt centré sur
l'appareil génital masculin c'est le cas
et vous dites pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
qu'on dit ça me
va être bloqué un petit peu
je veux pas de doucher à tout de machin
truc au niveau de la robinetterie
j'aimerais bien que les choses pas trop
gros
puisse facilement laver la vaisselle en
dessous parce que
souvent on est gêné avec un petit
robinet quand même
moi j'ai pas l'habitude des petits
robinet
[Musique]
se dire mais en fait c'est fou toutes
ces insultes qui effectivement
c'est un problème jusqu'au moment où on
se dit mais en fait non parce que je
techniquement ça ne me casse pas les
mais du coup ça me casse quoi moi et
c'est pas mal
vous avez raison c'est exactement ça on
va pas se marier je vois pas l'intérêt
et lui il aime pas non plus bah j'ai
découvert des fois dans des interviews
il disait qu'il allait me demander en
mariage je me disait le con j'espère
qu'il va pas faire ça d'accord
[Musique]
c'était hier donc la première
demi-finale de l'Eurovision cet univers
parallèle dans lequel les saxophonistes
tentent de féconder leur instrument
[Musique]
et enfin pour tous ceux qui étaient
inquiets sur l'état des micros de
l'Assemblée la semaine dernière ne vous
inquiétez pas ils prennent soin de cette
semaine
à la lumière
[Musique]
attendez c'est bien la parité en
politique mais c'est bruyant
ça c'est dur hein
le progrès c'est de permettre aux femmes
de rester à la maison
Marine Le Pen
le président de Mediapart est de vie
pleinel a porté plainte contre vous pour
violence vous l'auriez agressé dans un
restaurant parisien le 22 février
dernier est-ce que vous confirmez est-ce
que vous pouvez en dire plus est-ce que
je confirme que je l'agressais ou j'ai
reçu la plainte
les deux c'est un peu comme une fausse
dame mais petite elle est très gentille
même si elle parle pas vraiment dis Papa
c'est quoi Mimi Mathy
[Musique]
[Rires]
normalement c'est beaucoup
de je suis désolé
[Musique]
j'ai pas reçu la plainte je l'ai appris
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut savoir
pourquoi
pourquoi on peut pas savoir
la France n'est pas un pays à prendre
comme une femme non mais c'est pas
possible François Fillon un poids pour
Pierre Lescure j'ai tenté de promouvoir
des femmes au maximum bien que nos
dossiers soient très techniques
j'ai décidé de politiser mon arrêt du
cinéma par ces mots publiés par Télérama
l'actrice adelanel annonce stoppée sa
carrière en France l'artiste ajoute
vouloir dénoncer la complaisance
généralisée du métier cinéma vis-à-vis
des agresseurs sexuels et plus
généralement la manière dont ce milieu
collabore avec l'ordre mortifère
écosside raciste du monde tel qu'il est
une image aux États-Unis avec ce coup de
tonnerre l'ancien président Donald Trump
a été reconnu coupable d'agression
sexuelle sur une ancienne journaliste
l'effet se sont déroulés dans la cabine
d'essayage d'un magasin il y a à plus de
25 ans il devra lui verser 5 millions de
dollars d'indemnités ce verdict est une
auquel me correspond pas Jean Carole
pourtant quand on lui a montré cette
photo où elle est ici Trump va la
confondre avec son ex-femme Marla
mappels
pour moi la famille idéale c'est la
femme de l'ancien temps dure à la peine
les hommes à table
ça décharge il y a très longtemps non il
y a pas de problème
de Beauvoir a déjà publié le deuxième
sexe on avait voilà donc
j'en suis dans 30 ans on dira sur la
déclaration de Sarkozy oui mais c'était
l'époque oui bah c'est toujours un peu
l'époque quand même
outre le fait que la séquence est
absolument zinzin la bourde de Trump va
s'avérer quasi fatal